[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vettel il ya deux ans cela pour la
première fois je me suis jamais imaginé
en train de créer des présentations
on m'a dit ça m'a mis à mort il faudrait
que tu présentes quelque chose tu as
quelque chose à partager a dit quoi les
crayons
j'aime pas trop je suis à titre alors
j'ai cherché cherché je suis dit ok je
vais parler de quelque chose qui me
passionne
ne commencez pas vous poser une question
qui sont dans la salle qui sont sûrs
qu'ils sont de l'ethnie fort levier mais
s'il vous plaît
ok merci qui sont ceux qui sont de
l'ethnie yoruba et ça m arrive à son à
la salle ok voilà magnifique j'adore
mais déjà voyez-vous le bénin déjà avec
10 millions d'habitants
nous avons près de quarante six trous
ethnique voyez vous la différence
culturelle
chaque roue avec ses codes culturels et
c'est distincts est différent maintenant
allons à l'échelle de l'afrique 54 pays
d'état d'état détail des tas de codes
culturels
voyez-vous la culture pourquoi j'ai
décidé de vous parler de la culture
je suis artiste mais bon c'est pas ça la
met la culture c'est ce que nous avons
tous en commun
jeudi c'est notre valeur ajoutée c'est
ce que nous avons à vent nouveau nous et
moi c'est ce que nous avons à vendre aux
autres c'est notre différence qui fait
notre particularité la culture se
définit selon l'unesco comme l'ensemble
des traits distinctifs intellectuelle et
et je me perds un peu intellectuel et
affectif spirituelles et matérielles qui
caractérise un groupe d'hommes
donc c'est ce qui fait la différence
comme je l'aï dit précédemment office et
la culture pourquoi est ce que c'est
important aujourd'hui de s'approprier sa
culture déjà en à prendre l'exemple des
grandes nations
cependant l'exemple de la chine moi
quand j'étais plus petit plus jeu
chaque fois que je regarde un film
chinois après j'avais envie de faire du
kung fu je ne sais pas pour vous mais
pour moi c'était une carte et les états
unis avec le loup jean jacques bolle
bouzid gens croient de culte ans
aujourd'hui a décidé de mettre au panier
de faire dix ans voilà des grandes
puissances de grande puissance qui en
sur le plan économique des politiques
pour talmont différence totalement
différentes mais qui ont quelque chose
en commun elles ont décidé dans tout ce
qu'elles font dans tout ce qu'elles font
de partager leur culture
de fait la promotion de la culture et
c'est ce que moi aujourd'hui j'aimerais
que vous retenez de ma présentation
la culture c'est ce que nous avons avons
maintenant nous les jeunes comment
est-ce qu'on peut a pâti de la culture
se frayer un chemin créé une activité
parce que c'est possible
malheureusement aujourd'hui campagne
l'entrepreneuriat laisse jeunes et où on
pas souvent d
internet de l'agrobusiness et tout moi
j'aime pas les chronos je suis pas très
intelligent j'ai beaucoup plus mes mains
mais moi j'ai cherché ailleurs en tant
qu'artiste on ne peut pas vendre des
tableaux tous les jours non pas du tout
il fallait quand même d'une certaine
manière prouver des revenus qui en tout
le temps et d'une certaine manière fait
la différence parce qu'aujourd'hui tous
les jeunes ont de on va avoir le plus de
j'aime sur facebook on veut faire la
différence
ouais c'est elle qui fait ça et tout bon
moi j'aime pas trop la plus mais quand
même j'ai voulu faire quelque chose de
différent mais en maintenant dans ce que
je voulais faire je voulais fait la
promotion de ce que j'ai de ce que mon
pays m'a donné souvent je dis faut pas
attendre que le pompeï tu donnes quelque
chose va comment se passe votre pays par
lui donner quelque chose en retour le p
te donnera quelque chose c'est comme ça
moi ne fonctionne donc j'ai décidé
d'utiliser mes dessins de les mettre des
dessins du patrimoine béninois et
monuments qu'on voit les faits
quotidiens et ou de les représenter sur
des objets au fait et tout ça c'est mon
exemple un mois et en dehors de cette
saison et d'autodéfense et à des gens
qu'on peut utiliser
il ya dans la culture béninoise est dans
la culture africaine et notre culture
les ressources jeudi toutes les cultures
sont commercialisables
il ya quelque chose de commercialisable
dans toutes les cultures
on prend par exemple les recettes de nos
grands mères qui sont là depuis des
siècles on oublie un parce que ça se
perd malheureusement la pratique et tout
ça se perde on prend l échographie qui
sont là depuis des années qu'on utilise
peu les tisserands dans le domaine de la
mode aujourd'hui je me dis on peut
toujours prendre quelque chose dans la
culture et intégrée moderniser pendant
le cas de régis saisie qui assure
la galette la chine compte d'achille
qu'on aime pousse le prix national
avez vous déjà il a su exporter un pont
du bâtiment qu'il n'ya meninois il a su
moderniser cela angélique kidjo qui
aujourd'hui dans cette chanson et tout
le reste utilise beaucoup des chansons
d'inspiration que vos bouts on ne sait
pas beaucoup de ça prend mais oui elle
utilise beaucoup de chansons
d'inspiration vous nous elle va puiser
dans sa culture
excusez-moi famille tous les artistes
béninois actuellement les seuls qui est
comme ça donc d'une certaine manière la
culture amener là où elle est et je vais
pas trop m'attarder je vais finir
simplement pour dire que en toute chose
si vous êtes un jeune et que vous avez
envie de vous lancer
même si c'est dans le domaine de
l'internet si c'est dans l'amour dans la
culinaire à la culture aura quelque
chose à vous apporter livre vous dites
pas que non en maintenant la culture de
côté vous allez forcément j'en fait la
différence lors ignoré la culture dans
votre pensée que la culture n'a pas sa
place dans votre business c'est faire le
choix d'être comme et c'est notre valeur
ajoutée à tout un chacun sait ce que la
culture comme l'est c'est ce que le
togolais ils peuvent vendre aux béninois
et c'est pas ton je passerai je dirais
que je suis fier d'être béninoise parce
que c'est mon patrimoine culturel bref
en tant qu artiste passionné de la chose
c'est ce que j'aimerais partager avec
vous aujourd'hui et avec le monde entier
merci je suis fier à 12 ans